the number of lawmakers turning the heat
on the Attorney General Jeff Sessions to
turn over documents related to the phony
Russia probe continues to climb don't
ask now
he's one of the list of lawmakers that
are jumping in House Majority Leader
Kevin McCarthy and House Majority Whip
Steve Scalise congressman Scalise joins
us now congressman good to see you I
know you're in better health I am very
thankful as well as many other people
are you won't come right out and say
it's time why well first Sean thank you
for the prayers and the support I
appreciate it getting better every day
but like I support chairman Nunez and
what he's doing because what he's been
doing is uncovering the truth and
frankly there's a lot of things we've
already found that raise serious
questions about what the FBI is done in
possibly abusing the FISA Court there is
more that we need to get information on
and look the the FBI stonewalling I
don't know why Justice is trying to hide
information but we're gonna use every
tool we have to get the facts out and
ultimately continue this investigation
Sean yeah well we know that rod Rosen's
team for example begged Paul Ryan know
not to release the information that
ultimately became the Nunez memo up to
the final hour after Bennett subpoenaed
a long time
we have slow walking we have redactions
we have claims of national security that
turn out to be false and erroneous
right Congress has a constitutional role
of oversight they have a right to these
documents I know the Attorney General is
recused but this is congressman
Congress's role and they are not
providing them the information that they
legitimately deserve right Congress's
role is this function that we've been
actually carrying out the Oversight
Committee and if you look at what
chairman Nunez in his Intelligence
Committee have been doing they've
already uncovered a lot of things that
raise real serious concerns about abuses
of the FISA Court but there's still more
that we're doing in this investigation
and chairman Nunez ought to have every
tool and use every tool to get this
information and we're going to get this
Shawn one way or the other
the FBI and the Department of Justice
are going to have to comply but think
about this question Shawn we've already
raised serious questions about bad
apples at the FBI the FBI ought to be
working with us to root these people out
why would they
things like this they sent this document
this was one of the documents they sent
over practically the entire page is
redacted this is ridiculous so we're
going to continue working and doing our
job to get this information and chairman
Nunez has been doing a great job and his
committee at uncovering more but think
about this Sean this shows you where the
media wants to go with this all day they
want to talk about Russia and unrelated
things the economy just this week posted
new record numbers we've got the lowest
unemployment right now since almost 20
years ago we have the right track wrong
track is always an indicator of what's
going to happen in elections we crossed
50 percent we're at 57% right now where
Americans think we're on the right track
my president would present you back in a
month and they're still playing this
game will you demand will you support
contempt absolutely whatever chairman
Nunez thinks is the right course of
action to get the facts out I strongly
support because we're going to get to
the bottom s one way or the other all
right congressman we're glad you feel
better welcome back